there are five days left to campaign
before election day and president trump
and democratic nominee joe biden
are not wasting any of that time biden
had a virtual meeting with public health
experts yesterday in his home state of
delaware
while mr trump held rallies in arizona
where he said this
about the coronavirus and a safe vaccine
is coming very quickly you're going to
have it
momentarily that eradicates the virus
and we're rounding the turn regardless
you know that
that claim does not match up with the
guidance of the president's own task
force
reportedly it has warned governors of a
quote unrelenting broad community spread
in the upper mid
in the upper midwest the midwest and the
west that will require
aggressive mitigation to control the u.s
reported more than 78 thousand new cases
of the virus yesterday alone
the president's chief of staff mark
meadows joins us now to talk about all
this mr meadows thank you for being here
so we got a record case count we've got
hospitalization surging
we've got hundreds of americans dying
every day what is the president talking
about when he says we're rounding the
curve
well we've been making great progress
with
regards to therapeutics vaccines i think
he
the lead-in that you had there talked
about the vaccines
we're extremely encouraged by the
progress that two particular companies
have been making as it relates to
vaccines
some 100 million vials of of those
vaccines we expect to be deployed within
the next 60 days
and so as we look at that we do believe
that we're rounding the corner in terms
of the approval
as you know we've we've had since
february and march uh
really this uh coronavirus that's
affecting every family uh
around the globe and yet we still have
to make sure that
we allow science and our medical experts
to be able to come up with
with treatment to actually address it in
a meaningful way
you know we're seeing uh right now in
europe uh
even a surge that's higher than what
we're seeing here in america
and so those mitigation efforts that
we're taking along with vaccines and
therapeutics
hopefully will allow us to return to
normal in in the coming months well i'm
glad to hear you say hopefully because
that doesn't seem to be the message that
the president is putting forward and i'm
curious i want to just clarify what the
white house's position
is regarding the coronavirus we're all
hopeful for a vaccine we're all hopeful
for those therapeutics you mentioned in
the meantime
does the white house still want people
to socially distance wash their hands
and wear a mask oh without a doubt i
mean i
i can tell you that i probably have used
more purell than any american
uh uh here in the united states uh over
the last seven or eight months uh
making sure that we socially distance
wear masks when you can't do that
if you're you're in those environments
uh obviously uh
we continue to get tested you know we're
we're testing a lot more people we
we get a lot more cases that are
asymptomatic well that's the problem
with this virus
that's the problem with this virus as we
look at this
is sometimes we have a spread from
asymptomatic people
so you could uh have no symptoms i could
have no symptoms and yet
we're we're spreading uh uh to to loved
ones or
or friends and so as we look at that's
why the therapeutics that if
we you're absolutely right important but
well
the reason i want to jump in here is
because all right i i just want to
clarify
you know i'm glad to hear you say that
you're using purell and that people
should socially distance and wear a mask
that is not the example being set by the
president i believe was asa hutchinson
on sunday on face the nation who said
it's a little confusing for people uh
you know the president himself
your office the vice president's office
they are not following their own
guidelines
can you see how that's a problem for
people well
well i i can tell you that that i'm
following the guidelines and
a number of us are following the
guidelines look at it obviously
obviously a number of us continue to
to look at this particular environment
and
and it's an unusual environment that we
have and and so as we
as we try to make sure that we come into
contact with other people
making sure that we socially distance as
much as possible
wearing those masks when uh when we
can't uh
we strongly encourage that i also for
all of you that are watching this
morning
uh is if you can carry a little uh
container purell i mean
just think about it in a restaurant
environment you know you're
you're drinking uh from a drinking glass
well that
drinking glass probably has been filled
by a waiter or waitress that has
touched every other glass and so i'm i'm
hyper vigilant as we look at that
we don't think about the ways that we
potentially can become infected well mr
meadows i want to ask
with 13 states hitting record highs for
coronavirus hospitalizations the death
toll on the rise again
what is the administration's strategy at
this point to get us to the point when
we have a virus
i mean there was the head of a hospital
system in tulsa oklahoma said two days
ago
i just fear we are entering a very very
dark winter
well i can tell you that when we look at
that it's obviously the therapeutics of
vaccines but we know what doesn't work
we know that
that long-term lockdowns and shutting
down our
our economy and making sure that
everybody just stays
inside their house doesn't work we've
tried that it didn't work
it didn't work in europe and we're
seeing actually a greater outbreak
because of that in
in europe where they they locked
everything down and now that they're
opening things up
uh they're actually over a hundred
thousand cases in in europe
and so we know what doesn't work so
let's go ahead and try to learn from
from the pr past seven or eight months
to make sure that we
we adjust to that listen everybody wants
to get back to a normal way of life and
when we look at that
uh you know you you've got moms and dads
that are tuned in right now when are
their kids going to be able to go back
to school
are they going to have to miss those
weddings and funerals
we've got to find a way to do that and
the president is working around the
clock 24
7. he's encouraged his entire staff in
fact he's demanded his entire staff
uh to do that and i think that in the in
the weeks to come between
november december uh we'll have some
great announcements
that will give the american people hope
but in an editorial
in the new england journal of medicine
uh this month
titled dying in a leadership vacuum the
the board in a unanimous editorial
for the first time by signed by all
editors said that your administration
has taken a crisis
and turned it into a tragedy what's your
reaction to that
well i would i would disagree with that
when you when you look at what we
we have we look no further than the
state of new york and the number of
deaths that happened in new york city
early on in in this process and how it
spread
what happened and and slowing the spread
was a critical part of our strategy
not only flattening the curb but making
sure that people had hospital beds
if if they became infected and you can
look at the number of deaths in new york
versus the number of deaths in other
states what we've been able to do is see
that the death rate continue to go down
and and we will not stop there's too
many but we're not going to stop we're
not going to stop
until the death rate is less than that
of a flu
and hopefully that vaccine will help us
get there yeah mr meadows
the the dropping death rate is cold
comfort if the case count is going up uh
you can ask a statistician
about that one well that i would
strongly i would strongly disagree with
you
is is that obviously if if the case
count is going up
and we're finding that that the
fatalities go
go down where what we're experiencing is
less than we
mr meadows we are facing a 911 like
fatality rate every few days here in
this country still so i think the
american people are going to make a
decision based on the record of your
administration
in controlling and containing the virus
versus what the plan
of the byte administration would be
that's the choice uh before us uh you've
laid it out and we appreciate it uh
it's very clear it is a stark one
there's no there's
there's no one that believes that one
death is too many more than me
or my wife or our family any time that
you lose a loved one
uh it's critical it's it's important
that we address that
the president has expressed that over
and over and over again
and yet the rallies continue we have to
we've got to take a break here mr
meadows we've got to tuck one in we
would have you back again soon though uh
good luck in these final days on the
campaign trail mark meadows thank you
very much